hello everybody and welcome to let's
play a number of the Black Plague I
lefty you off with me putting this
crystal and here it's in there I know it
oh yeah oh yeah I got it
alright what's this all I could learn to
live with this what's this a shot like
gosh oh shut up
ah what the put the odds shaky
oh I'm going crazy oh god I can't see a
damn thing
what the f what the effing app oh boy
oh it's chasing oh no no gimme gimme Oh
give me up there Oh what the f Oh get
out of my way
oh what's this what's this oh my battery
battery Oh what's this I'll go oh I
don't know what you do but go oh I hate
chase Thanks
oh oh steam Oh God light God is so dark
get out my way rock oh oh yeah oh yeah I
win I win hardcore oh I went hardcore
okay that was it right whatever it is
with the substance in tow I was close to
ridding myself of the disease once that
was done alright there we go okay
oh what'd you think oh wow good I don't
even care honey
care get out here yeah not
no fu man I'm I know you don't you know
I even gonna not even gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna be slowed down because yeah we
are end of the line
no bull uh-huh no thanks for the laughs
only laughs were mining just a potion
and a big fetch cruelly oh hell yes
times yep yep oh yeah here we go Boop oh
what's up good except then another right
put that yeah ah yeah yeah oh yeah here
we go oh boobity boo [ __ ] Chiquitita do
you do what the hell oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh it's that last missing piece
that I missed huh you say mister oh no
where is it oh boy oh no oh no oh it's
in here it's in here I just missed it
I'm sorry guys I'm such an idiot
where is it oh where is it is in her
hair
hey there no I didn't see it maybe I'll
get there we go
no um I'll [ __ ] me off oh [ __ ] me maybe
under the shelves I checked on top of
the shelves I didn't check under them
okay all right I can do this
oh I'm smart I think I'm smart I think
I'm smart
oh please be smart
oh please be smart uh I hope I hope I
hope I hope I hope
are you hiding something
containers you hiding something no just
you hiding something
helping hiding something is anybody
hiding something anybody anybody anybody
oh yeah oh oh yeah oh oh yes yes oh I'm
so happy oh I thought it was gonna be
another goose chase oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah get ready Clarence Oh boobity boo
Boop
oh yeah Federative oh please no f you
man
fu that gonna get up oh I got ball
bigger than you do nope nope nope nope
nope I got this Oh failed to inject
sample what the hell is he
I know you wouldn't know you dad puts me
this scared what the hell yo what the
hell no reaction please input new
sequence Oh No okay
okay so it's a combination what do I
have a note
oh if you man okay no okay that's not
the right one
no okay half me
ah oh god I'm gonna be stuck you forever
oh [ __ ] me oh oh [ __ ] me
it put compound mix oh I got a note from
oh um antidote oh yeah okay um let's see
ah okay asset oh how do I know which
ones either are oh man I do not know I I
don't know what the f what the f what
the f do I have nothing to hint me along
the way
oh I turned out the light probably
wasting yep from wasting Oh what the
hell what the hell
Oh guys am i stupid I'm stupid
oh no oh okay there has to be something
in these notes there has to be let's see
okay they'll automatically be stored in
that order and stored default setting
okay Louis okay oh yeah yeah the lower
button row got reverse numbering make it
the rightmost start at four and
increasing the left okay it's one two
three four okay I got it I got it
chlorine is is two but its first one is
two on the top it's 2 it's 2 1 2 1 4 2 1
4 6 2 1 4 6 5 1 sort of four six five
two one four six five three two one four
six five three two one four six five
three ah yeah Oh give me give me the
Cure oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah get rid of the voice in
John's head he's gonna go away he's
gonna die oh yeah oh yeah oh yes gone
gone get away oh I'm so sorry Annabelle
all I wish I'd had done that before oh
I'm so sorry I wanted my hug
I want my hug guys oh I need a hug
Oh
okay all right ah what the
wait why that finally couldn't bear the
stress of the chair nothing nothing can
withstand the chair yeah
ah oh it's it's alive oh [ __ ] you
Oh get ready for a chair oh you are so
getting the chair
Oh get oh oh
if you man oh okay get away
I'm trip got [ __ ] in it get away
oh hey you Oh get away get away get away
get away
Oh F Oh f of Oh get away Oh pinky oh no
side pain oh man Oh
get back Oh get back oh I hate you you
are not getting the best of me I swear
to God I swear to god guy I swear that I
saw Zeus are you sure a Buddha Oh
anybody anybody oh no no no no no no I
will take you on bring it on oh [ __ ] oh
I [ __ ] you no no what the hell is
happening oh wait what at the end this
one was more human than uh-huh what what
happened
or his action uh-huh sorry okay
you conduct what do I do
what the hell is going on whoa huh man
this took a deep steep dive swan dive
into the WTF zone
ah man oh I wasn't afraid anyway oh I
will gain everything is niche Howard mom
John's daddy huh really
oh yeah finally realize that I am
awesome
desire yep uh-huh
oh you don't want to see me when I'm
angry yep chuckles little wonder you all
a different direction
yep Oh
okay huh
oh yeah I'm so gonna beat the crap out
of every one of you every one of you
every one of you in the face with my
fists
Oh get ready get ready for the pain what
the hell whoa all right um I'm gonna
take out quick oh that's I don't know if
you guys could see that but that's a
little it's a little graphical error
going on I don't know what that is all
about anyway I gotta take a break here I
gotta cut it but I will see you guys in
part 17 of let's play penumbra the Black
Plague bye bye